today marks the first full day in office
for Montgomery Alabama was first
african-american mayor that Stephen read
he made history yesterday when he was
sworn in to lead the city that was the
first capital of the Confederacy during
the Civil War
Montgomery also played a key role in the
civil rights movement dr. Martin Luther
King Jr's march from Selma ended with a
rally on the steps of the State Capitol
there back in 1965
Jericka Duncan joined mr. Reed on a tour
of his city to see how far Montgomery
has come I remember that night when the
returns came in that was a very exciting
night for mayor Reed that's what some
people even compared it to the night
that President Obama President Obama was
elected people in Montgomery will tell
you that they thought about that too but
this mayor Stephen Reed really envisions
a Montgomery that is Unova unified which
has not always been the case in a city
known as the cradle of the Confederacy
[Applause]
it's been a long time coming because our
hearts and our actions
I stand here in a position that many of
those who were sold on the banks of the
Alabama River just a few feet from here
could only have imagined this is the
culmination of those distant dreams 45
year-old Stephen Reed made history
Tuesday becoming the first
african-american mayor in a city marred
by an ugly history of racial injustice
we must be a city for everyone we must
not just talk about equality
we must act in the interest of equity 63
year old Cheyenne Webb Christ Berg
attended the packed inauguration
ceremony she was just 8 when she marched
alongside dr. Martin Luther King jr.
from Selma to Montgomery in 1965 to
support voting rights for African
Americans she was even there on Bloody
Sunday the state and local law men
brutally beat and injured more than 50
peaceful marchers I have
the opportunity since being that little
girl to see the first african-american
man in Selma the first african-american
president and today the first
african-american man so help me God
Steven Reed is a man that has really set
the tone in the cradle of the
Confederacy here in Montgomery Reed
story began in Montgomery Alabama where
he was born and raised his father Joe L
read some folks say politics is dirty
but politics is a noble profession
it's parlor tricks that's bad was a
longtime chairman of the Alabama
Democratic conference did you know you
always wanted to be married no no way
definitely did not know that I wanted to
be mayor and didn't plan on it so what
happened what changed I think for me I
grew frustrated with the lack of
initiative and some of our political
leaders and lack of political courage
some of the most courageous actions
taken that catapulted the civil rights
movement into the national spotlight
happened right here in Montgomery thank
you for all the support I appreciate it
[Music]
the day before being sworn in then mayor
elect Reid took us on a tour as we're
walking closer and closer to this plaque
memorializing Rosa Parks this is
significant this is arguably where it
all started
yes protesting and change has always
thought they'd been in the DNA of people
here we stood on the steps of the
Capitol where dr. King spoke of a time
when injustice would no longer prevail
it's a great sense of honor to be able
to lead a city with such significance
with such a history like Montgomery
foreign nation still at times embroiled
in conflicts over Confederate monuments
and race it appears Montgomery is making
strides thanks in part to the people who
could see this moment well before it was
realized what do you think dr. King is
saying
now as you're standing in the same place
that he stood many years ago you know I
hope he's proud it took too long you
rewind the history of this country it is
complex it is complicated but it's one
that is ongoing and so I'm just a person
that's kind of carrying the baton right
now and hopefully I'll be passing it on
to a new generation with a little bit
more progress being made than we are
where we stand today Reid says key
issues he plans to focus on first are
the public education and criminal
justice systems in Montgomery but as his
work cut out for him without a doubt but
very optimistic he said that he has
three kids his two youngest already
asked him if he's going to run for
president sounds like a very humble guy
but the symbolism is really profound
powerful yeah I was gonna say I love his
dad as well you know the problem is not
politics it's a trick yeah I like that
he's 45 because I remember watching
election night thinking he looks like
he's 25 yeah but when I said to Jericka
how old is he jury contribute it's
coming up in the next but 45 and he
seems so ready for this job he's ready
and it was interesting to hear that this
wasn't something that he had his eye on
necessarily but just felt it was time it
was time for your Qi was known as the
cradle of the Confederacy it'd be
interesting to do what it's known for
going forward it's time for a new
chapter all right we'll see them in for
education we'll be back read yeah a
follow-up congratulations you can hear
more of Jerry quz conversation with
Montgomery mayor Stephen Reed Congrats
to him on today's CBS this morning
podcast listen wherever you like to get
your podcasts